big debate in america over bringing back
mass mandates the white house is
reportedly considering telling
vaccinated americans
to cover up again but there's an even
bigger fight over coveted restrictions
that is coming
cnn is now pushing vaccine mandates
there's one thing that bind
administration can be doing right now
that would change the equation when it
comes to incentives
and that's to use proof of vaccination
if they could say
get the vaccine you have a proof of
vaccination
you can take off your mask that would be
really
key and i also think that vaccine
mandates are something that will have to
come
and dr fauci is praising a new nfl rule
that would force
teams to forfeit if unvaccinated players
cause
outbreaks and they can't play a game
what we're seeing is an indirect way to
pressure people in a positive way
of saying that you know if in fact
you're unvaccinated
and you get infected that's on you and i
think that's what the nfl is doing
so it's a way of functionally mandating
without explicitly mandating so greg
there's this new
obsession in the white house press
briefing every day almost now for the
past week of a reporter asking jen
stockey why doesn't the government
mandate the vaccine and mandate vaccine
passports it gets repeated over and over
again and it's not really a question
it's more of a
like why aren't you doing this kind of
thing this is their new thing
is is proof of vaccination
yeah it's uh how do they do this if like
if you're not wearing a mask somebody's
going to come up to you some kind of
force is going to come up to you and ask
you to see your papers
i mean this is some pretty chilling
stuff right it's kind of
yeah it's weird but um but i've been
thinking about this because we've been
talking about this forever we may be
dealing with this forever if what if
covet becomes this everyday variable
uh like traffic and weather you know so
you get up in the morning you check your
traffic
you check the weather updates the
forecast the smog forecast and the covid
uh the coveted cases or is there's a
slight like you could actually do it
like weather there's a slight bump in
covid over here in the southeast you
know it's like
so if it becomes like a mund maybe
that's the solution is that it becomes a
mundane
variable in our life so we dial down
all this moral judgment and this theater
and we pull back on the thirst for
i don't know power because if we're
dealing with this every day
we can't be politicizing it every single
day and judging people because they're
skeptical
people you can't blame americans for
being skeptical when it was the
government that participated in gain and
function
it was the experts who knew the risk and
then denied it
and then it's the media that buried the
concern and labeled anybody who thought
it was
important racist because it was linked
to china so
forgive forgive americans for being a
little bit skeptical
of of of authorities people in power
and if they start talking about orders
americans don't take orders we follow
laws but you give us an order you're
going to have some trouble and it and
and you know i'm saying this to somebody
that's vaccinated and i'll
keep getting vaccinated because i like
the feeling of not wearing a mask
it makes me feel free and naked but just
so you have to keep your pants on
pants are a must be wearing so jesse i
think we have to dial back the
fear panic that they're they're starting
to push i mean the majority of the
country is vaccinated
there's herd immunity from natural
infection and they're acting like if you
don't get the vaccine that your chance
of dying is very high now that might be
true for certain groups of people
but for people who are not getting
vaccinated young people for example
their chances of surviving coded are
coveted are upwards of 99 percent